check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below
you can also use a discount code salam
10
for 10 of their products assalamu
alaikum what i'm talking about okay
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are wearing inshallah
today's video is
a important video this is a video from
sheck of man who is based in california
who does dawah quite actively and who
has uh
basically buried a few people around the
tower table he has you know david wood
uh sam chamon uh and the other few
cowards as well
who've been buried there well the only
one is david who keeps resurrecting and
dying in the same spot over and over
again
uh but anyways let's get straight to the
point in shovel now his dawah as you can
see
it seems like it's getting to them dao
in general gets to the enemies of islam
the disbelievers by the way now this
believes the two categories allah tells
us there's two categories there's those
who are hostile and those are
not hostile and we know in sort of
montana verse eight allah makes it very
clear
that those were hostile and kicking out
your houses and fire you based on your
faith
you should be gentle you should be just
unkind with them
so now we're gonna go through what these
this this hostile disbelievers
their psychology and how it is and we're
gonna look at the prophet peace be upon
him but before that let's look at his
video of a death threat that was sent to
sheikh
of man here we go alhamdulillah
brothers found this death threat on my
car today
we know your car we know your house
you guys do whatever you want we're not
stopping dawa this is what i think
you know my house you know my car come
do something
so the letter reads the following sheikh
uh urman
oh there's a tea sorry it's like utman
we know
your car we know your house stop dava
david or die sense of islam
so basically brothers and sisters allah
makes it if you look at the quran if you
look at the seerah
of the prophet peace be upon him and the
hadith you will realize something very
important
that when the prophet peace be upon him
first came with a message
um it was not uh taken that seriously it
was just something that
whatever okay when things got a bit
serious in the context were a lot it's
the people started to come into islam
then what happened was it uh the prophet
peace be upon him even he was known as
the truth for one so
they never accused him of being a liar
they accused him of other stuff
so then he was kind of ridiculed yeah
then he was just
kind of like ridiculed don't take him
seriously hahaha whatever it may be
and then slowly slowly what they did is
they started to realize
that they have to make a case in the
context they have to challenge it
academically intellectually and in those
days poetry
was very uh commonly known so they
realized that maybe we can challenge it
and
you know bring something like it allah
gives them a challenge as well when they
challenge them academically
intellectually they realize that
actually we can't do this we can't even
we can't even do that so they came to
the realization
that they can't even do that now after
that what happened is they started to
get
hostile because they started to realize
we can't intellectually academically
and in other shapes or forms challenge
it so we will go a little bit hostile
now this could be pressure
this can be verbal pressure this can be
swearing this can be insults and this
can be
deferred you know which comes on later
but then you will start to realize that
slowly slowly
fights broke out you know um a certain
facebook
between the sahabah and the mushrikeen
yeah so then afterwards you would see
that certain things of
boycott starts to arise you know you see
boycotts starting to rise don't buy from
them
disown them etc with what a lot of
reavers go through
then after that what happens is bronze
sisters an
outright boycott and we're talking about
the process
and his companions were starving
literally starving kicked out
you know boycotted full out now
after that you will see that now it
became a matter of
life and death yes torture
killing wars began and that's the reason
why if you read the quran the battle
better the better or
the battle of khan you name it yeah the
battle of
um all these battles if you look at them
you will see
that the muslims are in a defensive
position yeah
and subhanallah and this shows you and
tells you the psychology
of the hostile disbelievers yeah the
hostile disbelief is like people like
this filthy scum
this sam and this david and even now
you've got
this feel-free scum dog this little
piece of crap yeah we know
what he's about he's now he's defending
christianity he's flipping a
puss yeah you're possible yeah
so much so now he's jump on the
bandwagon he's defending the
christianity
you can't make this stuff up i'm the
lava anyways um you can see the
curse on his uh on their faces anyways
there uh especially this april's guys
yeah
uh what a lost course what lost course
is his his video is not even getting
views anymore his channel is literally
nearly dead
okay they're irrelevant now this whole
ex-muslim thing is irrelevant
now you see that how hostile they get
now the reason i'm mentioning this and i
want to
wrap up on this is the following that
you will see
that they talk about freedom of speech
give
us allow us to have freedom of speech in
the western world in their in these
lands
give us this freedom of speech while
there will be millions
thousands of people coming to dawa just
by shakhtar of mines that was still 10
plus people have come to islam
we just allow us you want to talk about
freedom of speech work against freedom
of speech
allow us freedom of speech and see what
happens without violence
people will come to islam and that's
what allah says in the quran
i can't remember exactly what he said
struggle with them do a great jihad and
the scholars say what is the great jihad
it is the quran allow us to speak the
kalam of allah you're going to see
people coming to islam and that's going
to bother you so much that now you are
resorting
to death threats to hell with your death
friends
you will never stop us be your shaykh
with man be a mansoor
be rasheed be whoever it may be you are
never going to stop our tower
unless you kill us and then guess what
you kill us thousands more would come
this message is never going to stop off
i know you've been watching this sam you
little coward
business a [ __ ] little puzzle animus
coward you'll be watching this all of
you guys
die in your razor allah says in the
quran when they are at home
in their houses they bite their hand out
of rage
die in your age till next time assalamu
alaikum
do not forget to subscribe to one
message uh i think the channel is called
um
i'm sorry i told you one message
foundation and inshallah when i got to
california the first place i'm going to
do that
is that stool inshallah till next time
i had